in november davidson solely assured his
colleagues in the european parliament
that his doctors were helping him get
back to work as soon as possible
i came down with a bad case of pneumonia
but he never fully recovered and was
taken into hospital again last month
his spokesman confirmed on tuesday that
a 65 year old died from immune system
complications
zasoli had been president of the
european parliament since 2019
it was a short stint punctuated by
illness but his role was an important
one
after three decades as a journalist the
italian became a european parliament
member in 2009.
during his election as president 10
years later he called on the european
union to swap nationalism for peace and
equality
we want to go towards the future in
friendship
just a few days before he was admitted
to hospital in december he met the
daughter of russian opposition leader
alexei navalny
the two awards her father the european
parliament sakharov prize for freedom of
thought
sending a clear message to russia that
its arrest of the kremlin critic was
what he called an offence to the
international community
he also criticized european countries
for not equally sharing the task of
hosting afghan refugees fleeing the
taliban takeover of afghanistan last
year
and he was critical of europe's
far-right politics and its impact on the
migrant crisis
today is a very sadness day
we are soaked and devastated
by the loss of our colleague our friend
our president david sasoli
he was a
very pro-european fascinated
worker in our
institution
david zasoli died just two weeks away
from the end of his term as president of
the european parliament
a vote for his successor begins next
week